for what reason does the gentleman from  alabama rise  mr president i and 55 other members of  the united states house of  representatives  object to electoral votes of the state  of nevada  in order to protect the lawful votes of  nevada and all other american citizens  section 15 and 17 of title iii of the  united states code requires that  any objection be presented in writing  and signed by a member of the house of  representatives and a senator  is the objection in writing and signed  by a member  and a senator mr president is in writing  but unfortunately  no united states senator has joined in  this effort  in that case the objection cannot be  entertained